I think that the most important the most
important thing about running a company
is to remember all the time what a
company is a company is simply a group
of people and as a leader of people you
have to be a great listener you have to
be a great motivator you have to be very
good at praising and looking for the
best in people you know people are no
different from flowers if you water
flowers they flourish if you praise
people they flourish and and that's a
critical attribute of a leader you know
there is there's a very thin dividing
line between success and failure when
you start a business from scratch and
you know if you don't have enough money
to pay the bills you go the wrong side
of that dividing line and if you can
somehow get enough money to pay the
bills
you stay the right side of that dividing
line you know I've always been running
running running faster than perhaps I
should me and I have great difficulty
saying no to things so keep on taking on
new things and we've just managed to
stay the right side of the dividing line
over the last 50 years in business but
but equally in those early days when you
when you're starting a business without
any financial backing it's it's it's
easy to slip the wrong side and in fact
you know most entrepreneurs do do slip
the wrong side and the important the
important thing is then just you know
pick yourself up and you know start
again and if it doesn't work at that
time keep keep going until you do
succeed and not to give up you just
watched two amazing clips with Sir
Richard Branson take the next three
minutes and sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]